Jenna Ortega's captivating portrayal of
Wednesday Adams in Netflix's Wednesday
has captured the imaginations of
audiences worldwide her magnetic
performance not only left an incredible
mark on viewers but has also profoundly
resonated with the legendary director
Tim Burton he candidly admits that
without Ortega's invaluable contribution
the project might have languished in
obscurity in a mere 20 minutes Jenna
Ortega accomplished what many actors
can't in a lifetime can you believe it
she left the legendary film maker Tim
Burton utterly Spellbound as Burton
reminisces without the perfect star this
intricate project could have been dead
in the water the weight of her role
combined with the magic she infused on
screen LED Burton to passionately
declare for me she basically made the
show that way he's one of my favorite
directors I've ever worked with he's
such a sweet guy